Bernie Sanders reacting to a report
about the median American rent payment
rising by 60% since 1960 sent out a
tweet yes yesterday saying this is a
crisis we need national rent control so
here's all I'm gonna say about that I
read that and I thought you know maybe
at this point it would be easiest if
Bernie would just provide a list of the
things he doesn't want to control just
give us that list because I've lost I've
lost track of all the stuff he wants to
control as well it's a list that list is
far too long but we could never keep
track of all of it so maybe if you could
just make a list of it make a list
saying okay this is what I won't try to
control and then we can assume that
everything not on that list is under his
jurisdiction so what would that list
consists of that's what I tried to
figure out if Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren or to make a list of
the things they don't want any control
over what would it be
it'd be a very short list indeed well of
course the first thing they put on there
is is the border they don't want to
control that government spending don't
want to control that the woman a woman's
right to kill her babies don't want to
control that and I guess that pretty
much is it I think that's it that's
that's the entire list three things
everything else though is is for them so
glad we got that cleared up all right
let's talk about some good news for a
change good news that also has a
negative spin to it that I so I will of
course be talking about that as well
because that's that's what I do every
every silver lining has a black cloud as
I always say so president Trump has
announced that he will speak at the
March for Life which is happening
tomorrow in DC he'll be the first
presidents who ever speak at the March
for Life 47 years they've been doing
this
they've been doing it every every year
it's in DC right where the president of
course lives this will be the first time
that a president will appear in person
to speak so last year he was the first
president to speak the video feed to the
March now it will be in person that
he'll give his address and this is gonna
be a big moment I think for the movement
for the March but it also highlights and
in you know I I think it has to be
remarked upon that March for Life has
been happening for 47 years
have been several
Republican presidents in that timeframe
and none of them have gained to come out
and address the March for Life not
Reagan not Bush one not Bush two I mean
they they they hit in the White House
probably under their beds cowering as
half-a-million pro-lifers marched right
outside their door refusing to come out
and acknowledge these people in person
now that would be unthinkable in the
reverse for Democrats
can you imagine 500,000 pro-abortion
demonstrators well can you imagine
500,000 pro-abortion demonstrators in
general you can't because just the
pro-abortion movement could never get
that kind of turnout they especially
could never get it in a sustained way I
guess if you want to say the the women's
march in 2016 was a basically a
pro-abortion March which it was but that
has been as we talked about a few days
ago that's been dwindling into
irrelevance just in the span of a few a
few years now can you imagine
pro-abortion demonstrators every year
500,000 I'm showing up in DC and yet no
Democrat president addresses them
imagine 500,000 pro Borgia demonstrators
gathering in DC every year during
Obama's term and Obama refuses to come
out and talk to them for fear of what
his political opponents might say no
that would never happen you can't even
imagine it but that's what happened with
Republican presidents for 47 years and
for Reagan and Bush and Bush that will
be a point of shame for them always I'm
not saying that it defines their
presidency but it is something that will
always be a mark a stain on their
records in my view so it's great that
Trump is putting an end to that finally
and this is one of the things that
people like about Donald Trump is that
he's not he's not gonna be concerned
about it whatever the other Republican
presidents were worried about which is
hard for me to even figure out you know
you're you're Republican they already
know that you're supposedly pro-life
they hate you for that
as it is they're not gonna hate you any
more or less if you show up at the March
for Life so you might as well show up
for your own base but whatever
calculation the other those other
Republican presidents had made how
concerned they were with how people will
react to it
Trump is not concerned about that I mean
you think about what he's done
the first year he had Mike Pence show up
he was the first vice president to speak
then last year he did the video feed and
he was the first president to do that
and now this year he's showing he's
showing up himself in person what this
administration realizes to some extent
is something that I've been saying
forever that a lot of us have been
saying forever which is that the
pro-life issue is a winner it's not just
a winner because it's morally and
ethically correct it is a moral and
ethical winner
obviously scientifically it's a winner
it's the winning side historically it
will be seen as the winning side
but not to use the wrong side of history
cliche but indeed the the people in
favor of infanticide are on the wrong
side of history it's also a political
ring winner there's no reason to be
politically afraid of it to hide from it
to cower in the corner because our
message our argument is that you
shouldn't kill babies the human life is
precious and you shouldn't disregard it
and discard it and destroy it
that's our whole argument
it's it's a it is the definition of a
winning argument
and the frustrating thing is that to
whatever extent this argument has failed
to win the day which it has ultimately
failed to win the day but that's largely
because we've been afraid of making the
argument see a winning argument is
useless if you're afraid to make it you
have to be willing to make the argument
now you can disagree with the argument a
lot of people do but our position is not
one to be embarrassed by
it's the opportunity
talk about this and make this argument
should be something that any Republican
politician is jumping at
they should be fighting with each other
should we crawl they should be clawing
at each other for an opportunity to
speak on the stage of the martial life
I mean just from a political perspective
alone
to have that opportunity to be there
talking to a group of hundreds of
thousands of people young people mostly
women mostly female mostly young to be
able to talk to excited you know an
energetic and to be able to talk to this
crowd about the issue of saving babies
from being killed I mean again you could
not ask for a more winning point so it's
in it's something that we should put
front and center we are not the ones who
should be embarrassed by it we're not
the ones who should be embarrassed or
ashamed of our position on this issue
and I say that with all the so-called
social issues gender is the other big
one this is a winner the argument that
men are men and women are women and that
men should be in women's locker room and
mentioned be competing against women in
in you know track and field and
wrestling and MMA it's a winning
argument there's nothing that can be set
on the other side of it we have all the
points in our favor but if we are not
winning the argument it's just because
we're not making our argument you could
have a really good point
there could be someone screaming at you
and saying a bunch of nonsense and you
could have the most devastating rebuttal
possible but it won't amount to anything
if you don't say it if you sit there
silently whimpering and crying then
you're not going to win so that's why we
should be proud in our proud of our
position on this subject because it's
saying it's moral it's rational
it's the other side that should be
embarrassed and ashamed and Trump
realizes that but that which is which is
to his credit but that realization is
not complete because speaking at the
March is awesome
and and and I think will be a milestone
moment but the most significant thing
Trump could do the the main thing that
passed Republican presidents refused to
do with respect to the pro-life issue is
to defund Planned Parenthood speaking is
great speeches are fine that stuff is
important using the bully pulpit of the
presidency to make the case for life is
really really important and it's it's
meaningful but money talks right money
talks more than than than words do most
of the time and so far every Republican
administration every Republican in
Congress including the Republican
Congress that we had for the first two
years of Trump Trump's presidency and
including the Trump administration every
single one has chosen to continue
sending half a billion dollars a year to
the abortion industry to the
billion-dollar conglomerate that kills
300,000 kids every year every Republican
presidency every Republican Congress has
chosen to do that and this has so far
not been an exception every time you
read about a spending bill being signed
and there was just another one last week
Trump signed another big spending bill
trillion dollar boondoggle every time
you read that this is the Republicans
actively funding the abortion industry
it's not a passive thing it's not like
it's happening against their will
the funding for Planned Parenthood is in
that bill and they are passing it along
and then signing it and saying yes let's
give $500,000 or 500 million excuse me
five hundred million dollars to the
abortion industry but Trump still has a
year left in his term he still has a
year to send the message to Congress
that he will not sign a spending bill
that funds Planned Parenthood this would
be a great thing for him to say tomorrow
this will be you want to go out with a
bang and you want to have that speech
really mean something this is this is a
this is a something he could say
tomorrow he could announce that he is
not going to he pledges to defund
Planned Parenthood with his with his
with the final year of this term and and
and he's not gonna sign any spending
bill that has even a dime going to the
abortion industry he could do that now
would have been a lot easier to do back
when Republicans controlled Congress it
back when we had both chambers of
Congress and the presidency could have
easily done it then easily by the
Republicans didn't care to do it now you
can do it now our Democrats gonna go
along with of course not while the
Republicans could come up with a
spending bill it doesn't include funding
for Planned Parenthood Democrats would
need to sign off on it they're going to
refuse we know that's how it will go
they shut down the government if they
want to do that if Democrats want to
force a government shutdown in order to
protect the half a billion dollar
welfare payment to the abortion industry
in order to protect the gift that they
give to their own donors in the abortion
industry if they want to do that let him
do it let them let them take that
argument to the public this is an
argument again that we should want to
have yes definitely let's have the
government shutdown let's have a news
cycle about this you get out there in
front of cameras Democrats and you
explain to the public why you are not
willing to let the government even
function unless the abortion industry
gets its 500 million dollars there are
still plenty of people in this country
I'm willing to bet who don't even know
first of all don't know that we're
giving money to Planned Parenthood and
of the people who who do know that we're
doing that many of them as
mind boggling as this is many of them
don't even know that Planned Parenthood
does abortions they've done surveys on
this there are tons of people out there
don't even know Planned Parenthood does
abortions and if they do know it many of
them probably still buy this nonsense
about oh it's only 3% of what they do
which is a total absolute lie not even
close to true
the vast majority of their
non-governmental non tax income is from
abortions the vast majority I think it's
something like 40% total including the
governmental income or something like
that but it's a vast majority of their
non-governmental income is from is from
abortions so but this is see this is the
case we could make if this is what we're
talking about if this was is what the
news cycle is about let's talk about it
see the Democrats don't want to do that
that's the last thing Democrats want to
do they want to fund Planned Parenthood
and and just that's it and it fund it
and move on and not talk about it that's
what they want they don't you think they
want to defend it
you think they want to actually talk
about what Planned Parenthood does
you think they want to acknowledge
publicly that they themselves as
Democrat politicians receive millions of
dollars from Planned Parenthood and
donations do you think they want to talk
about how this is basically a money
laundering operation for them
where they send money over to Planned
Parenthood and Planned Parenthood sends
money back to them in the form of
donations I think they want to talk
about that no they don't
so let's force the conversation I see no
downside I don't see one what's the
downside some government workers you
know have their paychecks delayed for a
few weeks
I understand it's an inconvenience I do
but this is an inconvenience that's
worse that's worth the the cost all
right now a word from LifeLock if you
want a new year's resolution that's easy
to keep you can resolve to help protect
your identity and personal info with
LifeLock identity theft protection
LifeLock alerts you to potential threats
to your identity they see more than what
you can see by just monitoring your own
credit you know this this is something
we should be doing of course and you
should sort of be on top of that but
there's a lot that you can't see like
info on the dark web for example and if
you have a problem life locks us-based
restoration specialists know the steps
to take to help resolve your case after
all only one in five identity theft
victims who had accounts open in their
name discovered their their theft
through a bank or credit card company
and you think about all the all the
others who didn't find out of course no
one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but life lock is the new
year's resolution that's not only easy
to keep it'll help you protect what
you've worked so hard for this is the
most fundamental thing right it's like
your identity this is who you are and
somebody can come in and take that take
that from you well if you want to stop
that from happening
and think about all the things that we
protect well this is something that we
need to protect get life lock for up to
25 percent off your first year go to
life lock calm slash Walsh that's life
lock dot-com slash walls for up to
twenty five percent off
okay did you know that there's a Taylor
Swift documentary film coming to Netflix
if you didn't know I feel like you
should because it's yeah I'm certainly
looking forward to it the trailer for
this Taylor Swift documentary was
released yesterday Taylor Swift fans are
really excited about it it is it's
noticeable or notable I should say
because it is quite quite possibly the
most insufferable thing you will ever
witness in your life and that's just the
trailer for this thing I can only
imagine what the actual movie is but
here's a little bit of the trailer check
this out throughout my whole career
label executives would just say a nice
girl doesn't force their opinions on
people a nice girl smiles and waves and
says thank you I became the person
everyone wanted me to be
I I think that Taylor Swift she is
annoying my model friends to build eyes
like a Trekkie to skinny
nobody physically saw me for a year and
that was what I thought they wanted I
had to deconstruct an entire belief
system toss it out and rejected American
glory before me it woke me up from
constantly feeling like I was fighting
for people's respect I saw the school
and it was happiness without anyone
else's input
[Music]
I want to do this I need to be on the
right side of history Taylor Swift broke
her silence on politics okay boys in a
whole new way so this is basically
self-importance it's a movie that's what
this is and the whole plot or point is
Taylor Swift heroically courageously
deciding to break her silence and let
the world know that she is a leftist
that's what it is
we're supposed to be in all of her
courage of her courage that she a
celebrity in a left-wing industry in the
midst of a left-wing pop culture with
the left-wing media she was willing to
take a very very popular stance a very
popular political position one that
would be sure to receive applause and
adulation and would make all of her
friends happy Wow
what heroism what incredible heroism I
am I'm stunned by it personally
as a celebrity
above that
to come out and say popular things that
everybody around you is going to applaud
and most of your fans will like I don't
know if I could do it I don't know if I
would have the way with all for
something like that speaking of heroism
Becca Lewis is a PhD student apparently
and she's also has a large social media
following for whatever reason she took a
rather heroic stance against
stay-at-home moms the other day she was
reacting to a tweet from BBC talkback
which said let me pull it up so the the
tweet from BBC said will introduce we
will introduce you to a trad wife a
young woman who has chosen to be a
traditional wife staying at home to take
care of the household chores while her
husband works and she is fine with
submitting to her husband as he makes
the key decisions in their lives that
was the tweet talking about stay-at-home
moms who are basically culturally
conservative and take that approach and
live that kind of lifestyle
Becca Lewis responds who needs youtube
rabbit holes when you have the BBC
broadcasting literal white supremacist
propaganda
then she follows that up with for those
in my comments who don't seem to know
so-called trad wives or white
supremacist women who devote themselves
domestic duties in the service of
perpetuating the white race it is a dog
whistle meant to sound less white
supremacist than it is so stay-at-home
moms are perpetuating the white race
that's what that's what drives them and
she's got a point actually because I can
tell you my wife's estate home um and I
I can't tell you the man at the amount
of times she's come up to me and said
stuff like you know I have to go do the
laundry in order to perpetuate the white
race and it always seemed a little weird
to me but now that I think about it I
guess it might explain why she gets so
mad when I put lights in with darks I
don't know I mean maybe that's now it's
all it's all it's all coming together or
maybe actually this argument from Becca
Lewis is crazy
maybe crazy for too many reasons to
count but let's start with the fact that
it is one of those things that to try to
break it down and explain what's wrong
it's you're there's no way to fully
capture the craziness but let's start
with the fact that white Western culture
has been leading the charge away from
this kind of lifestyle
so a family that decides to live this
lifestyle a woman who decides to stay
home with her kids which I call it a
lifestyle making it sound like some
exotic strange thing which are which in
our culture it sort of is and that's the
point but really it's not exotic of
strange at all it's very simple it's
people have been doing it for is this is
how families have functioned many
families for census since time
immemorial since the dawn of human
civilization but it's a white Western
culture specifically and especially and
primarily that has been rebelling
against this
so a woman who decides to stay home with
the kids and be a stay-at-home mom she
is living a lifestyle that is very
similar to non-white cultures so this is
a lot more this is still the common way
of living in many non-white societies
and what about them are they white
supremacists I wonder see that's the
thing that and you find this a lot with
the left where they they criticize
conservative views conservative
lifestyle choices they criticize that
and they try to pin it they always try
to make it into a racist thing somehow
as tortured as that argument needs to be
they they try to make into a racist
thing meanwhile in so many parts of the
world in non-white parts of the world
what they're criticizing is the norm
you
so every dismissive and insulting thing
they're saying about these white people
they're actually saying about non-white
people more so
but of course what we what we know is
that when you when you find this from
from feminists especially this hostility
to stay-at-home moms
it's such a bizarre thing first of all
to be hostile to hey if you don't want
to live that way you don't have to a
woman who's at home with her kids and is
doing the laundry and cooking and you
know taking care of the house and in in
performing a you know I won't even call
it job I think sometimes you hear people
say in an effort to defend state-o moms
and say oh no that's a job it's so it's
more than it's it's bigger than a job
and it's not merely a job it's bigger
than that deeper than that right
people that are doing this like my wife
they're not hurting anybody even if you
disagree with it even if for whatever
reason you think it's a horrible way to
live I don't know can't understand why
but not hurting you not attacking you
all this stuff you hear from the left
about all we've to respect people's
lifestyle choices yeah it's completely
bogus of course
because here you have a lifestyle choice
that is not hurting anybody and has
definite benefits that can't be denied
Homam they're there with their kids
they're able to be a greater influence
on their kids lives because there they
are there and present more often
that there's obviously going to be
benefits that
and yet you are offended by it well we
know where that stems from it stems
primarily from a discomfort and
insecurity with your own lifestyle
choices you recognize maybe at some
level the nobility of that way of living
and so you feel attacked by because you
are insecure other choices that you have
made and it turns out you're not so
pro-choice after all all right more to
discuss but first let's check in with
paint your life you know when I first
heard about paint your life and how they
could turn any photo into a work of art
I first thought okay well this must be a
computer thing right like one of those
Photoshop things you can do or you take
a picture and make it look like it's a
painting and then I found out that no
it's actually a real painting
world-class artist painting by hand so
then my next thought was I'm a pet I'm a
pessimist if you hadn't noticed my next
thought was okay well then it must be
ridiculously expensive but no wrong
again very affordable real art done by
real artists if you want to give then a
truly meaningful gift you've got to try
paint your life calm you can have an
original painting of yourself your
children your family special place the
cherished pet at a price you can afford
from paint your life calm this is a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photo
I've done this myself
it's a very easy process on your end
anyway all you do is send them the
picture they get to work on it and
they'll communicate with you so that you
can see the progress and you can have
input on specializing it or
personalizing and customizing it in
whatever way you want so it's a very
easy process very hands-on they're very
very responsive during the process
because they know that what they're
making is something that's very personal
and important to you and they want to
get it right there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded it's as simple as that and
right now is a limited time offer get
30% off your painting that's right 30%
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word matte to
64,000 that's matte to 64,000 ma TT to
64,000
all right we're gonna do emails I
actually asked before emails I saw this
story about a there's a 111 day cruise
that's gonna be taking off soon or maybe
has already taken off 111 day cruise
eleven days on a cruise ship I guess
some of those days will be on land of
four day trips but I mean still 111 days
now if you've ever been
on a cruise you know how they go right
on a five-day cruise you'll gain easily
ten pounds and spend five hundred bucks
on alcohol because the drinks are
expensive obviously very expensive but
but they get you because you don't have
to pay up front for the drinks the food
is included but most the time the drinks
are not so but they don't want they
don't want you to have to pay because
then you'll probably be more eager to
moderate what you're buying so they give
you a nice little fun little card it
doesn't even look like a credit card
just like a little card and every time
you get a drink you hand them a card and
they just scan it and and then they hand
it back to you and it's real quick real
easy and and then at the end of the trip
they leave the bill under your door
showing you all the times and then you
start thinking you know what maybe I
shouldn't have bought margaritas for
everybody at the bar that one time turns
out that wasn't a good idea so and then
there's the food you know
non-stop food food all over the place
including an overnight buffet they're
gonna have like a pizza and ice cream
buffet overnight opens at midnight runs
all night
and then during the day there's just
food everywhere and the food is free so
you eat and you eat and you eat and by
the time you stop in Jamaica they have
to actually lift you off of the cruise
ship on a forklift and then bring you
down to the street and just roll your
Rotonda body down the street while
people stop and try to sell you weed
because this is Jamaica and that's what
they do with tourists now just imagine a
hundred and eleven days of that you'll
be eight hundred and fifty pounds by the
end of it in need of a liver transplant
financially destitute but it does sound
fun I have to admit fun and also
somewhat terrib-- terrible so let's go
to emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com this is from
Brian says I've been a listener of the
show for a while now haven't felt
compelled to email previously but after
listening to your take on billionaires I
felt obligated to do so I tend to agree
with most things you say so I was very
surprised to hear your take on
billionaires first you almost lost me
when you said that many companies
essentially use slave labor I would love
to see legitimate examples of this even
your statement that low-wage workers are
often exploited by big corporations
reeks of liberalism what is exploitative
about offering somebody money in
exchange for doing a service and
allowing them to freely go elsewhere to
make more money if they desire
additionally your statements that
someone owning a large house private
planes and multiple cars is grotesque
and immoral is in direct conflict with
your usual libertarian views consider a
significantly obese man that you see
sitting at McDonald's eating three Big
Macs and fries doesn't become the
responsibilities of responsibilities of
you or the government to inform that man
that he's grotesque and immoral and to
limit what he is able to eat also along
those lines you mentioned that in the
immorality of the situation when just
juxtaposed with the situation of
somebody living on the street freezing
to death by that logic you should open
your home to one of those individuals
and allow him to crash on your couch I'm
sure there's square footage in your home
that you don't use all the time so by
your own logic it becomes immoral for
you to possess it I look forward to
hearing your rebuttals on the show
tomorrow thanks Brian
okay Brian I'm I'm glad that you sent
this because it is exactly
exactly the attitude the approach from
conservatives that I was cautioning
against this is a this is a precise
illustration of what I was talking about
what you're demonstrating here in my
opinion is exactly the wrong way to go
about this because you are recoiling at
the very thought that workers are being
exploited anywhere and especially that
it could ever be immoral to hoard wealth
and luxury you're saying or you seem to
be saying that there's no moral problem
at all with somebody owning eight houses
and 20 cars and a boat and a plane and
while other people are living in the
gutter now I I think that that's just a
mistake so let's go through this one at
a time first of all I didn't say that
many companies use slave labor I said
that some have which is true you want an
example take Nike Colin Kaepernick's
employer how they infamously have used
sweatshop labor yes and I think that
using sweatshops in a third world
country is essentially using slave labor
some companies have done this some
companies still do this
okay do you deny what you can't do not
hit it's a fact that it has happened and
does happen so what are you gonna defend
using slave labor are you gonna defend
sweatshops now I don't think you want to
do that are you gonna defend company is
going to third world countries and
exploiting impoverished families instead
of employing Americans at a decent wage
the this this why would you defend it
it's a crazy thing to defend as far as
um as far as workers being exploited
again it does happen I'm not saying it
always happens or that every workers
exploited
that's what AOC was saying I'm not
saying but it does happen
unless you want to deny and say that it
never happens so what you're doing here
- seems to me is an extremely capitalism
this is an extreme form of corporatism
or consumerism
is it's not capitalism it's not even
really libertarianism this is like a
defend rich people at all costs
and it's just it's unnecessary and it's
wrong and it's unwise I think you say
that my view reeks of liberalism well to
be honest with you I don't care I'm not
worried about having my opinions line up
perfectly with conservative doctrine I
don't care about that when somebody
tries to I get these emails sometimes
right when I venture outside of the
conservative camp a little bit on some
issue I always get oh you sound like a
liberal all right I don't care hey I
really doesn't matter to me rather than
label the point of view that I'm
expressing just respond to it give a
counter argument but labeling it is not
a response and you know I
the first whole part of the show going
through and attempting to dismantle
Alexandria Kaiser cortezes absurd
socialist rhetoric about how all
billionaires are greedy evil lazy
exploiters that was my whole point the
whole first I spent 15 minutes on it
refuting that view
I explained why it isn't true it may be
true sometimes yes well it's probably
never true that a successful businessman
is lazy so what you was talking about
how they sit on the couch and do nothing
that's completely absurd I don't think
there's any successful business man
anywhere who's lazy those are two things
that are tend to be mutually exclusive
but greedy and exploitative sure yeah I
mean yes there are yes there are rich
successful businessmen and CEOs and
companies that are greedy and
exploitative of course
so why deny it again is my question
well I think I know why because then you
start talking about how people have a
right to buy what they want and we can't
have the government come in and tell
people what they can and can't buy and
how much money they can make I agree
that's my whole point I went into great
detail making that exact point yesterday
and many other days besides I absolutely
agree that the government cannot put
itself in a position of saying nobody is
allowed to make X amount of money here's
the limit you can't make more than more
than that or here's how many houses you
can buy you can't buy more than that III
agree with you on that I said that
specifically multiple times yesterday
that was my whole point for the first 15
minutes so when I say that something is
immoral that doesn't automatically mean
that I'm saying that government should
get involved if I think the government
should get involved I'll say it and I
have no compunction about that as we
know from talking about the porn issue I
said I think the government should get
involved and I made my argument for you
could disagree or agree but I'm going to
say I'm going to be very explicit about
it see people struggle with this these
days for some reason it's like any time
you call something immoral or say that
anything is bad it's automatically
assumed by both sides that you're
advocating for government solutions so
the response anytime you make an
argument that such-and-such is bad the
response is always well people have a
right to do that I didn't say they
didn't have a right to do it I'm just
saying it's bad I'm saying it's wrong
you you may have a right to do something
that's wrong but it doesn't mean that
it's not wrong and it doesn't mean that
it's that it we shouldn't point out that
it's wrong you know government solutions
and it's talking of how something is
immoral and then talking about
government solutions those two things
are not automatically paired they're not
the same
yes it is immoral I think for somebody
to be greedy and excessive and
overindulgent it's true that nobody
needs a 15 bedroom house and and
probably nobody should own one
it's it's mean if the word overindulgent
and greedy means anything it must apply
to that if you're gonna tell me that's
not greedy and over indulgent that I'm
gonna ask you what the hell is or are
you claiming that nothing is that that's
just a bit it's impossible for someone
to be greedy it is grotesque and opulent
and if you have the money for that kind
of thing you should be donating and I'm
not saying that we have a 15 bedroom
house you should have just homeless
people move into your home I'm saying
rather than buying a house like that
that extra money that it sounds like you
have that just burn and waste on your
own vanity probably should be better
used somewhere else with someone who can
use it
and I'm not saying you just go to city
and throw cash around I'm saying you
know find a smart and prudent way of
helping others
I mean can't can you really disagree I
ice if you have enough money to buy a
10th car maybe instead of that tenth car
you should give it to the poor
that's what I'm a my wrong are you
arguing that no actually the morally
preferable thing is to buy the car or
that it's neutral there's there's no
moral quality to it whatsoever
of course not
it you know it is it is it morally
superior to spend your excess capital on
a 20,000 square foot house rather than
giving the extra money to people who
need it and settling for a modest I
don't know five thousand square foot
house if you have a moral argument I'd
love to hear it but I don't think you
can
at least if you're gonna make a more
argument have to be very would have to
be an amoral argument would have to be a
nihilistic like well do you know
hedonistic nihilistic do what you want
drink for tomorrow we will die type of
argument but if you have any kind of
sense of objective morality and
certainly if you're a Christian it is
there's definitely no way of getting
around what I'm saying here your
argument about the government not
getting involved is irrelevant because I
agree
not saying that
I'm just saying it's something people
shouldn't do
the government stopped them no but they
shouldn't do it
I think people should be more charitable
and giving should be
you disagree probably not I mean I
assume you probably agree people should
be charitable and giving should the
government force it if people decide not
to be charitable and giving no I'm just
saying this is what people should do the
guy eating his third Big Mac he
shouldn't be eating three Big Macs yes
that is overindulgent that is gluttonous
that is self-destructive and it's
disgusting and you shouldn't be eating
three Big Macs
should the government stop him from
eating the third Big Mac no but he
shouldn't be doing it
and we should probably be sending the
message as a culture that you shouldn't
eat three Big Macs that's a good message
to send so part of advocating for
freedom if you're gonna have a pro
freedom message you need to have a moral
message too as well to go along with it
it can't just be people should be able
to do whatever they want it should be
people should have freedom and here is
what we ought to be doing with that
freedom
you're positioning it as though we must
we have to choose between a pro freedom
message and a moral message as if we
can't have both and this is the thing
that's endlessly frustrating for me
about conservatives these days that this
is this seems to be the attitude that a
lot of conservatives have now and it's
it's completely asinine I mean I don't
mean to be too harsh about it but this
idea that you know all we can do is talk
about freedom and but you can do
whatever you want and we're never
allowed to say you could do what you
want but here's what you should be doing
and here's what you should not be doing
I think it's a huge mistake and to be
ceding the moral ground to the left is a
huge mistake
and for them to be the only ones talking
about greed the only ones pointing out
that hey you know there are people there
are children living in the gutter and so
maybe you don't need to buy your tenth
house like they shouldn't be the only
ones making that point especially
because they do always put pair it with
government control so our response
should be you're right about the moral
part you're wrong on government control
here's why but we can't deny that
they're right on the moral aspect of it
when it comes to this
all right more emails to answer but
first let's talk about my friends at
Rock Auto with the ever-increasing
numbers of makes and models it's now you
know pretty impossible to stock all the
parts you need in a traditional chain
store front physical store
brick-and-mortar and so why endure a
pointless or seemingly you know just
never-ending litany of questions and you
don't really especially if you're not a
total expert on cars I'm not you get all
these questions and then and then at the
end of the day the guy at the counter
just gonna order the parts on this
computer anyway why do that when you've
got a computer probably sitting right in
your pocket and you go to rockauto.com
and just cut out the middleman one
reason to repair and maintain your cars
is to save money that you can then use
for other important things like mortgage
and food so why would you choose to
spend 30% fifty percent 100 percent more
for the exact same auto parts at the
store when you could just go online and
buy them chain store's have different
price tiers depending on if you're a
professional or a do-it-yourselfer
rockauto.com though it's the same price
for everybody and it's always reliably
low for everybody and you don't need a
membership you can just go on get what
you need and leave it's really easy
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Park customers online for
20 years go to Rock Auto comm to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules brake parts
tail lamps motor oil carpeting for any
kind of car that you have whether it's a
real nice classic car the thing you
drive around every day amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right Walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you this
is from Brennan says oh wise and
glorious supreme leader I finished your
January 22nd show and I was quite taken
aback after listening to you ramble on
about the issue of the rich exploiting
the worker then proceeded to provide no
solution whatsoever please allow me some
time to explain I would like to start by
saying I agree with everything you said
just a pair of right just to paraphrase
the majority of relevant billionaires
today did not make the money or did not
take the money they earned it with hard
work and innovation some are also guilty
of
vil overindulgence no one person or
family needs a twenty thousand square
foot mansion three yachts two planes etc
the outsourcing of labor to sweatshops
in China and using undocumented workers
here at home is a portent and finally
yes it is impossible to pull yourself up
by your bootstraps if you cannot afford
a pair of boots in the first place yes
that is an accurate summation of my
point thank you back to a Brennan so
what is your point
well that was that was my point you just
said my point were you just trying to
make your listeners aware that the world
is unfair okay let's just assume we all
knew that were you trying to save the
billionaires who do these things are
morally in the wrong okay fine but let
me ask you this what law do they break
and what law would you implement to
solve these problems
can you tell anyone tell me anyone that
was kidnapped and forced to work for
Apple should we pass a law that says
besos cannot Bezos cannot buy a fourth
yacht seem at my point is we can admit
that these are unfortunate circumstances
people are born into and that it's
morally unjustifiable from Zuckerberg to
live in his castle but there is not one
single law you could present that would
not itself be even more unjustifiable
sure I would like it if Walmart paid its
workers more but at the end of the day
$8 an hour as a greeter is better than
nothing and these companies make that
happen
well Brennan I've already covered much
of this in my last response by the way
the Walmart he actually is not an
example at all I think of a company that
exploits its workers they pay their
workers pretty well it's one of the
better companies in that regard average
salary for hourly workers is 14 bucks an
hour
not bad full for full-time workers store
managers are comfortably in the
six-figure range lots of promotion from
within that the current CEO started as a
part-time worker loading trucks at
Walmart warehouse back in the 80s so I
think Walmart is a positive example as
demonized as it is it's actually a
positive example I think a role model
for other companies to follow as I said
before I am not advocating laws or
government involvement I don't think the
government can solve the problem of
greed nor should it try so what's my
solution I don't have one I don't have a
solution I don't think anybody does and
this is gonna sound strange maybe but I
actually get a little annoyed sometimes
by the insistence on solutions because
sometimes there isn't one and sometimes
I feel like it's almost it is almost
again I know it sounds strange but it's
almost a dodge sometimes to say oh let's
talk about solutions cuz there isn't
always a solution
sometimes we're talking about human
nature and I you know I I might not have
a way to solve it
I've certainly it's certainly not an
easy solution not not a switch you can
flip not a five-point plan like let's do
this then this and this and then the
problem solved so maybe there isn't no
point but does that mean that there's no
point in talking about it are you saying
that there's no point in ever talking
about anything that cannot be solved
I mean well you've certainly you know
you've certainly disqualified all of
philosophy for one thing philosophy is
all about talking about the nature of
reality and of the human condition not
solutions-oriented not because you're
trying to solve it but just because it
is and we're talking about what is and
there's a real value to talking about
what is and and for to understand what
is so yeah you know what you say that
let's assume everybody knows everyone
doesn't know you heard my last email
there are a lot of conservatives who
would actually deny and do deny I think
unwisely and and absurdly deny that you
know there is really any real problem
with with workers being exploited or
with greed and and you know
overindulgence and opulence and
everything that is that is in fact
denied and you just heard it so I I
think to talk about it just to to
emphasize and to explain that no this
does exist and it is a problem I I think
there's value to that what was something
like this I mean what what is the
solution I guess I should say there's no
solution there is it's just if not a
solution that can be implemented from
the outside is my point and no there is
not a governmental solution really but
the solution is
um people just needs a
differently you know if we're talking
about the greed of people who you know
are materialistic and and you know
rather than helping the less fortunate
are living lives of opulence and luxury
which by the way it's not just rich
people to do that this is very much a
vice now shared by lots of people in the
middle class myself included to some
extent or another you know but what's
the solution to that I mean just didn't
be better act differently rather than
being materialistic and greedy think
more about your fellow man that's the
solution that's it
there I don't think there is any other
one
if you're saying well what if people
don't want to make better choices then
what's the solution there isn't one
we just go back to step one make better
choices they don't do that then we go
back and say again make better choices
that's all that we can do
but does that mean we shouldn't talk
about it no I do not think it means that
let's see I guess we'll leave it there
for today in fact though before we do
before we wrap up if you're a regular
listener you know we were just talking
about the March for Life and Donald
Trump speaking of the March for Life
March for life tomorrow but it's
tomorrow by the way it's not too late if
you live anywhere around DC and you want
to make plans to show up I very much
recommend it and you know the pro-life
issue is something you've heard me talk
about a lot because of how crucially
important it is but we know that it's
it's getting increasingly difficult
we know it's its most difficult of
course for the babies that are being
victimized and brutalized and killed and
those who speak up on their behalf are
increasingly punished we know that you
know last year the left went further off
the cliff passing the New York state law
that allows board abortion up to birth
the Illinois state law allowing partial
birth abortion so the left is getting
more and more extreme entrenching itself
more and more on the the side on the
pro-death side of things and in order to
protect that position they are trying to
punish and they're going after us for
example and they you know to try to shut
us down and going after our advertisers
and this is not unusual and we're not
the only ones that go through it live
action is one of the biggest pro-life
voices in the movement they can continue
to do some of the most important and
crucial work in the movement raising
awareness educating you know activism
when we did that the big rally in
Philadelphia back a few months ago in
response to the pro-lifers who are being
were being bullied their live action you
know they they took the reigns and ones
that once I went to them with it they
took the reigns and and organized it and
so this is the kind of thing they do
along with undercover videos exposing
Planned Parenthood and so many other
things they've been banned from
advertising on Twitter for their calls
to defund Planned Parenthood they've
been banned from from Pinterest
altogether they've seen their
advertising efforts warded on many other
platforms as well this is why our daily
wire.com members are so important your
membership helps keep our cameras on and
our microphones aren't on so that we can
you know spread the message of life and
that is why from now until January 31st
a portion of any daily wire.com
membership will be donated to live
action with promo code live action
remember that promo code live action and
that way you can support awareness and
education around the world on this very
important issue so join daily wire.com
and make your pro-life voice heard and
we will leave it there to everyone who's
going to the pro-life or to the march
for life tomorrow travel safe and to
everyone else and those at the March of
course Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
yesterday president Trump announced that
he would become the first president in
American history to attend and address
the March for Life which is taking place
as we speak we will examine how a man
who once called himself quote very
pro-choice became the most pro-life
president in American history
then Democrat impeachment manager Adam
Schiff accidentally explains why
Democrats are so eager to house Trump
before November as the impeachment trial
enters its agonizing second day and
Tulsi Gabbard sues Hillary Clinton for
defamation because we are living in the
greatest time line all that and the
mailbag check it out on the Michael
Noel's show